welcome back to another we're gonna
fight Towelie one of my favorite
Southport characters of all time I'm
very excited
apparently he's an ex drug addict that
now works at a drug store you go which
one town fun fact my my name casserta
came from Towelie when he did that he's
gonna end up getting high isn't he okay
[ __ ] Kuhn is so worthless I hate him
[Music]
Cartman is supposed to be the best
character right I don't know man and my
character is really bad too honestly
like my setup is so [ __ ] Mike come on
Mike our impression is some point yeah
I'm just gonna let Kuhn die cuz he's
worthless good sesh kids I'm gonna let
him take it
congratulations I have a burrito then
you [ __ ] [ __ ]
on fire you guys your leader is like
burning up here he's so great I love him
I'm just charging my ulti right now
because that's what's gonna make a
difference here this combat has a
special objective what really most
Commerce requires you to kill all
enemies not this one - do we tell you
must light all four weed piles on fire
man I am way behind I can't believe I
didn't realize okay well we'll keep
moving then actually do you think I can
just use my fire attack then I can't use
it there but I can you see here so maybe
it will burn no that isn't work come on
come on all right watch places with him
and then burn one of the wheel there you
go
why are there piles of weed anyway who
knows ok I get it now
you're the only one that can light up
the path oh my god my lord [ __ ] you what
kind of black magic oh my god what's
it's hand that's be forgiving and all
slaves free oh nice
that was such a weird episode
[Music]
and then we got one more let's just walk
over nice and easy we did it nothing
happened though all right let's get real
lit in this beer
hey radius I did the admission what is
happening there we go
the best attack yes out of it you all
right we did it
I guess it only works on Towelie like it
doesn't affect us for some reason back
up now get some granddaddy purple
shatter on the house come by any time
for you know we should count very names
finally we have that medicinal fried
chicken I understand it was KFC they
were referencing him so stupid
he didn't hit me at all but oh well
what can you do we're gonna get back to
class see the clients this gal in 10
while we're at it though why don't we
test that Callos ability see what we can
get
sorry that's the wrong buddy just a
quick little investigation see way if
it's worth then
wait we have to get there first I can't
be bothered excuse me do you want to
take a selfie okay great I'm glad we
agree on things now classy
[Music]
okay classes should be here plastic
should be here and it's gonna be nice
it's gonna be a good champ everybody a
good time I tell you
Wow man the PlayStation is so slow my
god here's a new kid now you got class
he's prescription damn well better hand
my prescription when it's about
[ __ ] time
praise Jesus I need this [ __ ] babe if I
don't get my medication I lose my
[ __ ] mind you know what I'm
saying I know what you're saying don't
worry girl I got you man the place y'all
[ __ ] need to go is you story that's
where they taking the cast you know what
I'm saying I know what you're saying
this is lettuce the new kid got the
Intel from Clancy not bad new kid what'd
you find out
it's the used orange in the northeast of
him classy says the cats are being taken
day they use storage we should have
known all right Kate classy safe I'll
get back to you guys soon Roger that
okay so we got to go to the northeast
side of town
oh the cab singing hey kid you're voting
vigilante from the news right that ain't
me me not a talker huh
well sergeant wants to have a few words
with you over at the station no I don't
wanna go to this dashing well I guess we
gotta cooperate be a good set of sin you
know Craig okay yeah oh my god what yeah
so it turns out gender is actually a
little more complicated than what we
talked about yesterday okay
could you come back to my office so we
could sort this out maybe huh
new do you guys want to take a selfie I
know you do oh that's a great one
hahaha I already taken with these
[ __ ] okay talk to mr Mackey maybe
we'll pick whatever is closer all right
whatever
this is do it brake seems so far away oh
wait we can't go here because the sixth
grader well I think I killed him time
fartole I see you oh of course we can
pause the time cart so how did we do
that again okay
now that didn't work
I use the wrong time fart sorry this is
the right time fun there we go okay how
about that okay now we can talk to
counselling okay our discussion about
gender wasn't a precise enough and well
you gave me some guidelines how to do a
more thorough path helping you identify
your gender my regret so much picking on
there now this is just annoying yes male
yes female no that means it means your
gender fluid what is happening right now
the next thing I want to talk to you
about with your gender is your sexuality
now a lot of people think that gender
and sexual art of design but know that
bud is mad okay
how would you describe the sex of the
kinds of people you find yourself
sexually attracted to are you attracted
to both binary genders male and female
or do you find multiple genders beyond
the binary definitions attract sexually
attracted to some genders or all genders
and sexual gender fluid yes
well I'm glad we sorted that out just be
careful okay because there's there's a
lot of people out there who don't accept
you for what you are and you're gonna
have to deal with them okay so uh but
come see me anytime
good talk principal thank you very much
domo arigato what a great talk I really
feel like we did a lot there oh my god
so much homework tonight
[Music]
hey that queer kid oh my God we're gonna
kick their ass again teach you to make
fun of gender fluid pansexual people
okay thank you beautiful
very nice
okay we're done mix up police station
here we go
let's enjoy okay so talk to Detective
Harris what are you supposed to be a
rodeo clown good one a long throw good
one okay let's go oh hi guys you're the
one who made the news last night huh
that's me the police can always use the
help of concerned citizens I guess we
can give our little junior detective a
special kitty case to work on all right
thank you
there's somebody new to town shaking up
the crime family oh man this is a real
bad dude a kingpin of crime it wants to
control all the drug that doesn't sound
like a small giant into this location
here I need you to go in and neutralize
them you lead point my boys will be
there after if you take out the drug
kingpin will give you this junior
detective badge pretty neat huh really
neat made a gigantic Guinea this is a
sidequest sir main quest
I can't tell it's all it's all merch in
this one I see I think it's a main
question doesn't pay crime doesn't pay
who are you supposed to be a drum major
he doesn't take sell food just anyone
how about that and wonder what happens
if you take a selfie with everyone in
the game cuz that just seems like a lot
of work and I don't really get what you
get out of it all right we can Fastpass
there's not enough Fastpass in the game
you gotta walk a lot man I wish I
wouldn't mind but the loading screen
between each one is like ah dude all
right
here we are at tweakin Bros I love
Twiggy it's such a fun character hello
welcome to tweet copy what can I
interest you in today and
Aksum nash Mochaccino please sorry young
man I can only take selfies with
customers
I will then ash it's like putting on
your favorite flannel shirt was a
pleasure
well it sure was a pleasure they had to
meet you there yes oh my god wife
they're really going hard on the fan
fiction stuff sorry what was my mission
find the suspect but it wasn't there
quite oh wait he's outside my bed okay
okay okay okay what is it what do they
say my batter has to talk to Craig all
right listen I have this expert who I
hate now and he still has my goddamn
laptop go get it from him but tell him
if he doesn't let you have it I'm
calling the [ __ ] cops
Davis tweek you'll probably fight about
his parents coffee house get my [ __ ]
laptop back for that prick is that in
here my god I was just there today I
need my laptop back for some reason
there you go we need to come up with the
perfect sunset blend okay well I guess
we're just gonna go back then and talk
to Craig about the guinea pig did I tell
you I used to have a guinea pig I think
I did tweek say about my laptop
fine you know wear stripes cages go get
up and give them to that [ __ ] [ __ ]
finally when you give that to tweek you
make sure he toes that when you walk out
on someone you don't get to make up the
rules anymore so they really weren't
dating huh Wow Matt it's an interesting
didn't see that one coming okay so I'll
do it later we I don't want to walk all
the way back to then go even though that
was a fast fast pants
where are you telling me I can't go here
[Music]
now I can go here okay okay I forgot you
have to follow the the law no I really
I'm done fighting okay I'm tired let me
just let me just do this quest right now
throw more imaging is showing the
suspect is in the rear of the house okay
what is this quest oh my god it's in the
rear of the house this is it boys am I
gonna fight this guy just oh this is a
drug-dealing all right we can if this
one is really good just stabbed with a
butter knife returned it back of course
of course that shadow okay well that was
an easy kill
I don't teach you to corrupt are you
good let me just kill a random I think I
know what's gonna happen
this town has to deal with please come
by and help us again we did it let's
loot his house while we're at it cuz
that's what you do after you go into
someone's house and beat them up in the
name of the law you betray the law law
you know that reference okay otherwise
it sounds really cringey
yes why so many loading screens so
awkward okay yeah we're okay Nia I wish
you could fast travel anywhere go to
crunchy microbrew okay that's our next
question al yeah okay yeah well I wonder
[ __ ] actually no see there's a fast
path right here anyway need to get
somewhere oh my god
yes take me here
the Fastpass is not a fast pace okay it
comes in and he's like II we and there's
a loading screen you have to walk to the
right place and then you have to walk
from there like I don't know man I don't
know man I wish you could pick not just
the fast fastest but whatever
okay I'll make the rules oh my god
you're slow
[Music]
super Craig ouch okay yeah and we need
to still fill out our character sheet of
course now you got a problem with me ah
piece of Prisma and do nothing while you
insult this man's ethnicity I wasn't
insulting him excuse me did you or did
you not say that this man seemed tired
yes he's my friend I said Paulo you look
tired
backgrounds have been stereotyped as
being sleepy
oh yeah shares a microaggression that
will not turn but I am you you're the
new kid right I'm the principal of your
school my name is PC principal I was
told you wanted to talk to me about some
race issues okay
come at me why
why are we fighting in nothing's
happening come on you want to learn
about rape right give me your best shot
I don't think we can kids nice day isn't
it tough wait why is wrong with you
you can't just attack for no reason try
again but I it's a nice day isn't it oh
stop wrong with you you can't just
attack for no reason
try again okay I'm not gonna do anything
not gonna do anything I'm not doing
anything yes very good that was indeed
not a microaggression all right round
two what I ate a hamburger
last week oh I have to spot the
microaggression okay okay okay okay
you will see how it gives you a free
shot only for the use of training this
young person in the ways that the social
justice warrior thank you Michael
Christian about to happen
my friend Brian looks like a chick like
Mike with drinks Saturday brunch in damn
not only is the word chick derogatory to
females but also criticizing a male for
looking feminine as a microaggression
towards personal transgender now let's
see if you can spot on micro aggression
it's more subtle oh okay pants are born
my pants are warm
is that a microaggression I don't think
so that copy belongs to Tim Sherman now
it's not a microaggression
I heard it's going to rain no that's not
a microaggression
Janet likes to roller-skate my crap now
what's wrong with you you can't just
attack for no reason try again what okay
all right
Genet likes to roll her skin fine it's
not a microaggression I don't know mr.
Yamashiro is actually a very good driver
dancer microexpression
hit his punching tan very nice indeed
using the term actually inferred that
maybe other Asian Americans are not good
drivers and the use of Mister is
offensive to persons a third gender now
before we talk about your race I need
you to get out there and do some PT work
for me I'll let you know when I think
you're ready
that was amazing I love this game only
we'll only South Park will make those
kind of jokes that's my job just about
the microaggressions can't seem to leave
this house there we go everywhere I go
left and right there's microaggressions
that I have to deal with this just wears
my cows it's my duty that's the thing
with social justice warrior they think
it sounds cool so they're like ya know
I'm standing up for social justice
meanwhile everyone is laughing at them
all right oh yeah we talked to Detective
Harry's okay cuz we attacked that man
african-american get mad thank you
hello yes back for more I got something
you might be interested in turns out
that scum you [ __ ] up is just the low
guy on the totem pole oh okay I see
is over here the real hey oh yeah that
happens to be any token town he's hiding
out some big luxury mansion bought with
blood money come back this is a whole
nother level little crime fighter his
house is like a fortress and we
maneuvered door is wired to a
state-of-the-art high-tech security
system you'll need this it's a
microphone I think we're just gonna
break in and attack black people I think
that's the mission here because it's
tokens housing first ten yep it's
definitely whatsapp this is that wrong
on many levels and I do not go by it
stand by it I will not I am a social
justice worry now look I have to go all
that way but there's no fast pass
there's no there's no fast pace well
well well the power of editing we'll do
this one just fine we go piss break or
something proceed past the gate and
around the back to find an entry point
what in the world is happening there I
will [ __ ] you up non-lethal eeee
I will beat you until my shift is over
sir
what yet he has a baton defeat the
security team others there's a team
that's time what uh-huh
oh wow
who should we take out first then him
were actually we could infect somebody
[Music]
you didn't get your
oh wow that was really tough oh my god I
took a long time I barely got through
but that was tough man oh me oh my
potato pie that oh gee I'm sweating I'm
playing on the hardest men mastermind I
probably shouldn't have picked
mastermind because I am NOT a mastermind
my god the challenge the challenge that
I have to go through while you guys move
the hacking device to the location HUD
spots oh my god I'm doing all kinds some
hacking over here yes everything is just
fine surging move the land land to the
hacking device that's great no problem
sir continue hacky
my god wow what a PHP transcoded
this is so dumb
did you maybe write the password down
anywhere sir like a notepad or something
yes yes must be something let's see let
me check in this drawer not again hold
on one more hack thank God they told you
Jesus
what is the point of this
good old matrix
[Music]
I don't understand how it's gonna end
hey Lilly tack it Matt guide we put the
microphone next to the cellphone a
middle name okay so I tell you what
let's just look up your account profile
and get a new password for you if you
can just hang on oldest trick in the
book oldest trick in the book
well if this is upper-middle class and
you can't damn boy it's got some whiskey
he's richer I wish you should take all
this stuff this is tokens house rich kid
what am I doing here come on I need to
find the right room damn it every nice
moment hey who the hell are you you
can't just break in here
[Music]
uh a really system you know and we're
just gonna beat up another black guy cuz
I don't know about this guy's please
just leave
oh he's strong and nuts Oh ace tokens
dead chokehold him what do you want I
want you to die oh well well we're
tapped this is messed up man this is
messed up brilliant work here oh you're
really getting into the program well I'm
kind of perfectly what we're doing and
you're doing it right along with us meet
me back at the station I've got
something for you
oh I can't wait what do we got for us
wait that's the party vigilante
[Music]
that's a good 40 come a little closer
you guys are dinner I'm gonna crush you
[ __ ] like microaggression wait I get
the punch sink is it in my creek I got
attacked on the way to the police
station my god
[Music]
thanks for dressing man that six Raider
either I'm not going to why but the
words crush and [ __ ]
trigger and particularly we're a
particularly negative reaction from me
Jimmy you've been fairly clear in the
past that you're tolerant views and
fight for social justice are to help you
and I quote crush push goddamn Jim quit
victimizing me Oh social media what have
you done what have you done social media
who are you supposed to be dork man okay
here we are at the police station let's
see what he got for me I'm excited in
the next episode thank you guys so much
for watching leaving it like all this
port has been amazing I love it it feels
like 2013 PewDiePie all over again thank
you guys bro fish squid BAM